this capsule we will see the concept
independence between random variable
so we'll say that two variables
random a and b are independent if
only if we have one of the three
following conditions where one demonstrates a
of the following three conditions to know
that the probability of rising
is equal to parity of all that the
morality of bessat chara is equal to the
probability of bep or that probability
of a and b the joint probability in a and
b is in party and galabru is marginal
twice the marginal probity so in
actually showed a selection to show the
three that is to say that we can demonstrate
each of his formulas from
from another of these three formulas and
so we understand better why that
corresponds one of independence in
various var at war on go focus and on the
first focus on the first
line here because it's from here that the
high politics if I observe if I
know the country value
it's equal to the probity of when
actually says is that my probability
probability a priori 2 1 remains the hand
even though I observe pays my uncertainties
my beliefs about your staying
exactly the same even though I
observed and so that's probably
intuitively actually it's a
illustration of the fact that there is no
dependence between b and a
that's why watching at
his hand not form on value does it
to observe forgiveness his hand shape not on
the value in an equivalent way
if we are dependent on believers on
b will not change if I have observed and
in fact the fate we can see quickly
that we get it from the fact that we have by the
polka and chaining that p2a knowing bcp
forgiveness p2a and bcp of knowing
belfry p2b messi gkp from high knowing
bettega the p2a I get well and well
so here are formulas that are the
equations that its equivalent
so let's keep a more concrete example
imagine that in my problem
identification for ja i introduced
a random variable that disciple
of Europe so intuitively for a co
realistic nor any relationship between the
makes that there is more gold and the fact that
I received an email that is a
email or not so what I would like
it's set up to model my
environment with probabilities
that they satisfy this equation secularism
so imagine that my model of my
environment and my models
probabilists corresponds this table of
joint probabilities if check if
I have well and that then and independent
of spam as I would you like it
see if my model is fine is good
true to reality then for that I
have to calculate the marginal probability
since then politics then be equal
to train 0.3 so the volt is that more
or even force it would be a minus that
so
1 - 0 point 30.7 and that I calculated that
by doing the amount disturb or rain
is equal to true then the policy be
equal to fos and justin - politics is
would equal the same way I can
calculate the probability that for
ensure true gala then the politics get
to be equal to false it would be a minus that
so 0.9 the man now for
check out the rain dependencies for
nothing I have to check for all
possible values ​​of rain or
spam is my probability
seals in my head of probity
is the product of the probabilities
marginal that I'm showing here then the
probability of rain and gala true and
to rot galas true is 0.03 is this
that it is equal to the product of the producti
marginal since is equals in a short time the
evidence a probability of spam
was that's the real one so it fits
at 0.3 x 10.1 is actually 0.03
it's equal to 0 point 3 x 0 point and I
so continues the probability that more
galley for nothing related to the strength that
that's who equals would not have been
attached 0.27 in my model is what
it's equal to the product of the pros
it's marginal but actually it's
equal to 0.3 which is the probability that
overuse guys the true faith 0.9 that is
the probability that spam is equal to
wrong according to my calculation of probabilities
marginal that I did here
and so on in this example if we
could check that for all
possible values ​​of rain and
spam I actually have that the
probability seal in rain and spam
it's equal to the product of the probabilities
marginal so I demonstrated that but
random variable in this case these are
well and independent then
independence is something that is
very powerful in his care that
greatly simplifies another model and then
probability calculations by cons
it's something that in general is
rare in an interesting environment
that we might want to model
actually what gives them
reasoning it is assumed that some
observations will allow us to
update our beliefs versus
to the value of other slaughterhouses so one
helmsmen the dependencies
unconditional is something we
would not often have that we can often
operated time a real model
noticed by contrast the independence between
the variables that allowed to reduce
substantially the size of
distributions to take advantage of my
random variable and so that's fine
allow to do some calculations that are
much more effective so in
the previous example
in fact I do not need to store the
four values ​​of May 2 marginal probity
pardon joints on rain and spam
so I do not need the table with the
four priorities
in fact I just need to store in
memory the probability since equal true
the higher the probability of more spam
equal true then from strains can
calculate all probabilities
joint on rain and quarries
and if I had a larger number of
values ​​at war that would allow me to
save there again more so
exponential
storage in memory of all
look that I need to calculate
any probability June
however as I said in practice
it's rare to be first situation
model where all the variables are going
to be truly independent
on the other hand we often see
introduce without having a model that
realize these independences
conditional then i'm going to use a
different example that is taken from the book
of rats norvig mice so this is a
example or imagine that I'm going to the
dentist and I would have too variable
random
do I have back pain or not?
that when the dentist uses that sounds
to check if there is a hole in
madam is what the probe hangs in
madam so that's going to be the variable
random eighth and do I have a
decay or not so in this situation
there if I wonder what is the
probability that the probe is hooking
of amada if I have a toothache and that
I have a cellar or whatever the value
of evil in what is the will of
crooked knowing thanks to a sore
teeth and the case where jean pebbles so
actually having a decay
hall forgiveness the fact that the probe
hangs it's absolutely nothing to do at
do I have a toothache or not if I
know that I have a decay the probe should
to hang then having to hurt or
employment should not influence the
does the probe hang or not so
in this case also the crooked politics
sacha toothache and carys equals true
it's actually I can reduce it as
being the cross politics at each to
riga the real then the network the same
reasoning applies if carrie and
regard ditch heap of topics meal of
caries I could actually reduced
the politics crusher toothache and
kariya the need for ego policy
sacha carrie equals must in this case
we will say that eighth and
conditionally to speaking two
toothache as she dances
that we added here that given a
other of Ariane in this case if carrie
so to take the example here summarize
that I bar carry on says
ret qxc crooked was dependent on evil of
teeth if I had that probity of a
crooked sacha toothache was equal to
the priority of eighth in the body
conditional we notice that the dense
that if I add carrie we will say that
crooked and independent of toothache
since harry if adding
teeth right so the part
conditional because i left and right
I have this equality the water here it's at
to say that to condition on the carry me
actually allows to eliminate toothache
that is, the tip and crooked
sore toothache and carrie is reduced to
the eighth note priority only knowing
because it's the same way we had
for unconditional independence we
had three equivalent formulas
because if that's equivalent to that and
it's equivalent to this formula here
so if we did for the definition of
conditional independence we have three
equivalent formulas
and to demonstrate that two variables
are continually independent of
Sasha another one just show either
this is it then to illustrate
the fact that with the expenses
conditional we can reduce the
complexity of our model
we will use the chaining rule for
writes the probability seals of hurt of
crooked teeth and 15 then according to the
chaining probity we only have 7 pro
class spouse and the probity of
toothache sacha hook caries them
two other variables times the
probability of eighth and carys enjoy
carry hooks can be used
as proof when we can write it
like eighth note politics knowing that
happens times the probity of carrie is
so this few lots here it requires
that I can calculate this policy
conditional the ai if this one is the
probability a priori here now if
I have a conditional independence
between toothache and eighths knowing
because here we will say that I can write the
political toothache knowing hook
caricom being simply
the reality of evil dance in shanghai
so that means that rather than having
need of both at the 3
possible probability to take advantage of
bad of dance at every rock because there is
has two to the gang because there are two
possible values ​​of malouda in front of the
possible of eighth note of possible value of
caries we have two at the cross not
been different from the own to m I can
actually simplified and then stored
only all the probabilities the
two to the 2 so 4 probability so
enjoy badly daring shopping because there
had had to map since two by the
possible bad value dates
possible from kerry now we can
also exploit the fact that
conditional probabilities like that
have sommières this means that if
I know the probability that bad of
teeth be equal to true I can deduce
the toothache policy is equal to
so I just need half
of these settings there when I need
just 2 e to the 1 2 two parameters for
model this table of probity there for
with the same reasoning I need to
two probability to have all the
possible qualities conditional here
and then I just need parity that
Carrie is equal to Le Havre to be able to
calculate either probability she receives
gala true or false so in all I
only 2 + 2 + 1 so five parameters
individual stored in memory for
ability to calculate all probabilities
possible joining ego evil and
who then this contrasted with the case where
I could not have taken them off
little so I could not have gone from
the step here at the step here if I had not
seen that crooked and independent during evil
of nantes is dependent on crooked
knowing that harry I could not have
simplify it as being only this
which I would need to store
dances only if four parameters
necessary for the calculation of this
conditional is here so I'm successful at
instead 4 2 2 + 1 so this share brings
so thanks to the functional expenses
I could reduce the number of parameters
that I attacked in memory for the
pros calculation
empowered that's a costume so I
not there to have reduced a lot but
finally have problems where I'm going
to be able to pass from an exponential man
from kind of to hate to a number
so linear from the top of n2 parameters
stored in memory
so we will be able to go from a body
exponential and light of a body that
is just impossible to do for
great values ​​of hate in a case that
is very reasonable
even for large values ​​of m
generally boarding
probabilistic conditional independence
it's really a concept that allows you to
represent the knowledge that is
very very useful they do more
to master this concept, that's fine
allow to model effectively
environments that are more
complex and that which involves a big
number of random variables